i was raised in a religious household
very catholic but catholicism they can
play it fast and loose you know
you were raised in a very christian
environment
and your early work in comedy was sort
of in christian comedy wasn't it yeah i
started in churches when i was 16
because you can't go up in clubs until
you're 18. so i hadn't been in a comedy
club until i turned 18
and
once i did i was like oh this is like
where comedy's supposed to happen not in
church not in church as it turns out but
you know i i think that maybe that was
good as a foundation i worked really
clean for like the first six years
probably yeah that i did stand up and
then when i turned 22 i actually got
fired from a church gig opening for a
big church comic because of something
that i tweeted that ended up being a
joke that i did on your show but this is
the joke that got you
sort of
kicked out of the christian comedy
circuit is that fair to say yeah it was
like the last
church gig that i was still doing was
opening for this guy and they called me
and were like hey like you can't be
tweeting stuff like this like we that's
not good for our audience can you tell
us the joke the joke was uh even today
i'm as an adult very sexually
conservative not that i'm bad at sex
okay i'll have you know in bed i am a
wild animal all right yeah way more
afraid of you than you are with
me i was so
happy that it ended up on your show yeah
because in my first late night set on
your show uh which was like by the way
all i wanted for years was to have a
conan set oh that's nice and it was
maybe the first moment that i felt like
oh i might be a real comedian now it was
like that's what i wanted for the first
half of my career like the first six
years and then once i got that i was
like okay we can set some other goals
now but that is literally all i wanted
to do and then after that all i wanted
to do was tour theaters and
now i've done that and so now everyone's
like what do you want to do now i'm like
i think i did everything i'm done i did
conan and this time
um yeah you tweet that joke out they get
upset but i i maintain
that
the limitations are great i think
limitations are underrated whether the
limitations are self-imposed or imposed
by your environment
it's really good for you in a way
because
you had to work clean and you had to
work within this very specialized
environment
so you weren't taking a bunch of
shortcuts that i think a lot of other
people would take especially at a young
age
yeah i think that's true but then also
coming up in church i don't think you're
exposed to as much stand up as you are
when you're doing
open mics and clubs in a bigger city
right because then you're more aware of
like what's already been done and what's
kind of a hacky premise and doing in
church gigs
nobody's really worried about that
because it's such a small
sheltered
scene i suppose you could say
so you know i look back on it and i
think in some ways it was really good i
was also going up in front of like
hundreds of people for 15 minutes and a
lot of times getting money and i'm like
this is stupid that should not have been
happening at all but by the time was the
money good is the is the money money is
amazing do they take it really do they
pay you like in ones and is it right
from the collection
i mean look they put it in your g string
but it's
it's blessed
they are the ones are damp with holy
water
i was paid in communion wafers for my
first three years you get a lot of free
wine you get a lot of
that's what's so crazy is like i had to
have a conversation with my team like
manager and agents where i was like i
can't do churches anymore and they were
like what about this money and i was
like i can't like i'm being dishonest
with them because i'm not a christian
anymore and i'm not going to be clean
all the time anymore i'm going to
speak how i speak in clubs
and talk about what i want to talk about
and if you are a
comedian performing in churches they
want you to be
that all the time and that's why they're
all you know middle-aged married guys
because they're christian and that's
their lifestyle and they talk about
their family and going to church and
you know good for them that's who should
be doing it but i didn't want to be
somebody who was pretending to be
something that i wasn't
for some sort of success or or
financial stability but yeah the money
was really good and you're kind of like
yikes like so then i just did like eight
cruise ships the next year to make up
for
it so you went from
christianity to cruise ships i have done
sometimes i feel like an imposter and
then i go i've done literally every gig
that you could possibly do like i've
done churches i've done corporates i've
done clubs i've done colleges i've done
cruise ships
i have done everything and i'm glad that
i have because now i know there are so
many different ways you can make a
living as a stand-up i mean when i did
cruise ships i was miserable i could not
have done more than i did but the guys
doing these cruise ships
they're like
they're happy that's their life they're
like in three months i have a land gig
i'm like a land gig
i gotta get out of here it's a way
different
the bar is very different yes ah to be
on land
what
in six months
terra firma
um
yeah
no but you know the nightmare that i've
always heard about cruise ships and i've
never
performed on a cruise ship you'll get
there i'll get there trust me
i i know my trajectory all too well i
will be on a cruise ship but um you'll
be on a cool like illuminati cruise ship
yes for like celebrities yes where the
real money is yes um they'll all be
wearing robes yes
i'll be nude uh
but
that's my preference that was not
anything they requested
a lot of people are wearing robes i want
to be nude um
but uh no the the
the horror apparently of working on a
cruise ship is that if it doesn't go
well yeah you are trapped with the
audience
for six more days
i've spoken to comedians who
it didn't go well and so they stayed in
their room the rest of the time because
if it doesn't go well at a club
or in a theater you're gone you move on
you literally get out of town the next
day
this is quite a different experience
where you're trying to go get your
spaghetti and meatballs
yeah
and you're in line and the people on
either side of you hate your [ __ ]
face yeah i would sleep all day until
about five o'clock which was right when
the buffet opened and then i would get
to the buffet right when it opened there
weren't a lot of people there yet and i
would eat very quickly and i would put
some fruit in a purse and then i would
go back to my room and i'd squirrel that
away and then i would go do the shows
and then
you know
go back to my room and then wait for
everyone to go to sleep and then i would
like go to the gym and walk around the
ship while it was empty and everyone was
sleeping
i can't believe i got depressed on these
right
what um with i'm always obsessed with
where the good crowds are are the crowds
royal caribbean are they are the crowds
on a royal caribbean decent yes they are
because they the ones that i did at
least they had a comedy club on the ship
which is you know it feels like a comedy
club in like toon town
where it's like this is what a comedy
club looks like but it's like you know
right and you only had to do like 25
minutes with another comedian and it's
free it's one of the free things you can
do on the cruise ship because it's all
inclusive so it was like
by the end of the week everyone had like
most of the people
were coming twice so like the first half
of the week these guys would have the 25
minutes they did and then the second
half of the week they would have like
the ship 25 that they did which was all
about what ports we stopped in and like
the buffet and all their ship jokes yeah
diarrhea yeah of course you got to get
to diarrhea who's got the imodium right
and uh
it was
but i did some that you there was no
comedy club you were just in like the
piano bar
and you would perform
stand up and it felt weird and people
were walking in and out and there were
kids at some and so like royal caribbean
was one that when i did it they had a
comedy club it was adults only and you
only had to do 25 minutes as opposed to
like 45 or something so i i only did
maybe like seven
uh weeks of it but and not consecutively
but by the end i was like these are the
only ones i want to do